I'm Jacksepticeye and today I will be
chatting with my AI self to see how well
it knows me
you pretend to be my A.I clone please
say no oh no sure I can role play as an
AI clone jackseptic AI oh this makes me
uneasy
top of the Morning Tia ladies that's how
I start all my sentences by the way my
name is jackseptic AI and welcome back
to another fun-filled conversation what
can I help you with today laddie
laddie I don't ever use laddie in my
day-to-day lexicon it's just for the
intro
let's see what it would sound like if it
was me takes a while to generate the
morning to you I'm jacksepticeye an AI
language model created by openai role
playing as an AI clone of jacksepticeye
what the
purpose is
the accepted guy
let's give it some soft balls first it
needs to learn what are your favorite
video games as an AI language model I
don't have personal preferences or
feelings good but I can tell you about
some of my favorite video games of
jacksepticeye the person I'm role
playing as okay now it's getting scary
undertale number one jacksepticeye has
often expressed his love for this indie
game which features a unique combat
system and a rich story two Shadow of
the Colossus it's on my skin baby three
The Last Guardian very good you could
have mentioned bloodborne or dark souls
or something what am I most afraid of
processing it better say something like
heights if it says like fear of
commitment or dying alone or something
I'm going to be wildly upset
jacksepticeye is mentioned in various
interviews and videos that he struggled
with anxiety self-doubt and imposter
syndrome at times
it's kicking in like many people he
might fear failure or the idea of
disappointing his fans oh God it's just
Heights maybe spiders I would like to
think that it just watched all my
content in a split second and then
realized that I'm an anxious mess what
else we got reveal something I don't
know it's like you've killed four people
back in the year 2002 and no one knows
about it did you know that honey never
spoils archaeologists have found pots of
honey in ancient Egyptian tombs that are
over 3000 years old and still perfectly
edible how's that got to do with me I've
just shared way too much online and
everybody knows everything so much so
that I had to start talking about
ancient Egyptian honey okay you react to
a video if I feed you the transcript I'm
gonna feed it by wired autocomplete
interview top of the morning to you
ladies based on the transcripts you
provided it seems like you're a very
successful YouTuber with a large
following and a distinct personality one
thing you may not know is that your
success has inspired many people to
pursue their own careers as content
creators and you've become a role model
for so many aspiring YouTubers
that's why the content on YouTube is
these days it sounds like I've died
I'm still here calling at relevancy
rewrite my YouTube Channel Bio top of
the morning to you ladies welcome to
jackseptic ai's channel where I an AI
clone of the legendary jacksepticeye
thank you legendary keep saying that
take you in a wild way through the world
of gaming laughter and pure excitement
join me as we embark on Epic Adventures
explore the depths of fascinating
stories and share Unforgettable moments
together this is so much better than my
actual bio
rewrite my Wikipedia to be more accurate
Sean William McLaughlin better known as
jacksepticeye he's an Irish YouTuber
video game commentator and online
personality born February 7th 1990 in
athlone Ireland no I wasn't I was born
in Balance law Hospital in Galway
jacksepticeye Rose to fame with his
energetic and engaging Let's Play videos
known for his distinct humor green hair
and Irish accent I've been doing this 10
years green hair was two years of that I
mean a lot of it is just random ass
information that's already from
Wikipedia it's like when I did a project
in school and then there they were like
write it in your own words but I just
went to Wikipedia and just like jumbled
the sentences around that that's what
this did come up with a new catchphrase
for my videos other than top of the
morning to you ladies what could it
possibly come up with that is better
than that as your AI clone jackseptic AI
I've come up with a brand new
catchphrase that captures your energetic
and fun-loving spirit power on ladies
let's conquer the game reversed together
if they ever make robots to talk like
this I'm gonna murder all of them should
we should we put it into the
text-to-speech and hear how it sounds
power on ladies let's conquer the game
verse together do you see why that's
wait let's see how this sounds like
if I said like a boss like a boss that's
not wait let's put more exclamations
like a boss let's add even more like a
boss
[Music]
[Laughter]
write a poem about a Horror Story video
game poetry by AI
in the shadows where Horrors creep a
chilling tale of a game so deep
jackseptic AI your guide through the
night to conquer the game reverse with
courage and might with every challenge
we conquer we Thrive Jacksepticeye and
ladies together we survive for in this
game verse where nightmares reside
jackseptic Ai and ladies stand tall
voice settings Irish oh baby through
trials and Terror our journey unwinds a
symphony of Screams and spine chilling
fine no stop apparently being Irish just
means that you say everything the same
way in the same tone over and over again
like a sports commentator at a hurling
match he's down in the end zone he's in
the field he puts it over the bar
do you have career advice for me number
one stay true to yourself your unique
personality and energy are what have
drawn people to your channel keep being
genuine and authentic I'm worried for
the people at home who are like I'm
feeling down today can you can you say
nice things to me and then the AI says
nice things to them and the circuit like
really involved with it the world's a
scary place anyway number two keep up
with trends like Chachi PT it's relevant
it's new it's the future baby engage
with your community interact with your
audience through social media live
streams and other platforms a strong
bond with your fans will keep them
invested in your content and support
your long-term success ah yes parasocial
relationships really are the future of
success it sounds like me from like five
years ago stay true to yourself and then
it's like but keep up with Trends just
do them in your own way but collaborate
with others as well I'm not going to
listen to this I can do whatever I want
I'm gonna do it out of spite now I'm
gonna hate my fans what should my next
YouTube video be oh this is what the
YouTubers of the future are going to do
they're just going to go to chat GPT and
then be like what should I record what
what's popular and then they'll go on to
have a million followers here's an idea
for your next video titled jackseptic
ai's time travel gaming Adventure that
is a horrendous title for a YouTube
video description join jacksepticeye as
he takes you on a thrilling Journey
Through the history of video games in
this special episode we'll explore and
play iconic games from different eras
starting from the early days of gaming
with Classics like pong and Pac-Man ah
yeah the YouTube algorithm loving bong
do you think you'd use this to help come
up with video ideas absolutely not if
these are the video ideas that my
Channel's dead already can I ask it when
I'm gonna die yeah when will
jacksepticeye die I'm sorry but I cannot
answer that question it's impossible to
predict anyone's death it's important to
focus on the present whatever what if
it's like 10 minutes whoops I'm not
leaving this room
AI is one of those things that
everyone's scared of people are like oh
so AI is so self-aware it's going to
destroy us all but when you actually
interact with it you realize that we
have many many years to go and we will
all be dust before that happens I
feeling it by outro
generate this bad boy thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see all you
dudes in the next video this one's just
for me jacksepticeye is so much cooler
than me and I eat my own pee pee and
people laugh at me when I do it dude
that's weird to admit online in front of
so many people what a stupid
foreign